happy belated birthday you just turned
30. so i'm curious you know what i'm
going to ask you are you 30 flirty and
thriving dirty and flirty and thriving
30 and flirty and thriving
i absolutely am dirty flirty and
thriving but more than that i'm 30
worthy and vibing
how do you feel now that you actually
are 30 is it what you thought it would
feel and be like why i really wanted to
make that short film you know the short
mini series that i made
to
take back the narrative of what it means
to turn 30 because i feel like there's
so much pressure on people i'm 13 year
old you what messed up universe did i
enter that my 13 year old self is on my
couch i want to be 30 flirty and
thriving it's all based on some line
that women can't have at all but what is
all and who made that list probably a
dude definitely a dude good point i have
never felt hotter i have never felt
wiser i've never felt more confident in
my life i feel like the 20s are just a
practice run for your 30s your 30s are
like your 20s but without all the
anxiety and and all of that so
i feel amazing i see the 30 balloons
that you just showed us how deep
how did you celebrate i had a small
dinner with some close friends we did it
here i set up a big table and had it
catered by my dream catering company
like they had this crab that they had
flown in i think from japan i'll show
you a picture the guy held the crab up
and it was like the size of his torso
and then they just prepared it in my
kitchen
it was crazy you know that the internet
was busy celebrating you online and
specifically a very
very touching message from jennifer
garner which you posted on your tick
tock you reacted to it people are saying
that you're 30 and that's like
weird because we've always played but
i'm 30.
so it's like
how can we both be 30 at the same time i
guess i wished on a dollhouse and i
didn't really age that's crazy what did
that mean to you well first of all just
the fact that jennifer would take the
time
meant so much to me and madeline's dough
made me a message as well madeline stowe
was one of the best teachers i could
have ever had on revenge she's just
brimming with talent but also grace and
the way that she always fought for what
was right for people around her and
jennifer's the same way like i just
learned from watching her and i remember
being stunned when i made the movie at
just how kind she was you know she's
this incredible movie star but she's
also just a really real kind person in
your short life you've played a version
of jennifer garner not once but twice
it's connor mead
i heard his uncle homeschooled him in
vegas for the last two years is there a
story that maybe you can share with us
that you've never told before that kind
of speaks to
her character and and your bond me
playing her in ghosts and girlfriends
pass was a function of jennifer speaking
up you know they were looking to cast
the role and they were like we don't
know what to do we're trying to find a
younger you and jen was like call up
christas
she's done this before and she's good at
it so
i really owe that role to her as well
have you ever had conversations about
sharing the screen yet again maybe in a
completely different capacity i would
categorize jen as someone that you know
i would always be open to working with i
think she's incredible but i also i'm
such a spiritual person like i put these
intentions out into the universe and i'm
not going to ever try to force anything
to happen so universe if you're
listening
let's manifest it let's get it going the
20th anniversary of the film is coming
up in just a few short years 2024 have
you started thinking about like i don't
know a cast reunion or what you would
want to do to honor this movie that that
means so much to so many people you know
it's so interesting that you asked that
i never expected things to take off in
quite the way that they did when i
started posting 13 going on 30 inspired
content on tick tock so i kept doing it
because i saw the joy it was bringing to
people
and then of course i had to acknowledge
everything coming full circle with my
30th but with the mini series vienna it
was always my intention to kind of
let it rest for a while you know not
talk about the 13 round 30 stuff so much
because i don't want it to be my entire
identity there so i think there's a
happy medium somewhere in between if
something in the universe brings us all
back together for the 20th reunion i'm
all for it but as far as my part in it
i'm gonna let it rest a bit
[Music]
my
cheers
it's divine
tik tok has been such an important part
of your journey you're coming up on
hitting two million followers did you
expect to add tick-tock sensation to
your resume you know i never did but i
feel like it's where you know all the
people who like didn't feel cool enough
for instagram we all went to tick tock
and like now we're just there vibing and
i love it i love it so much
and you my queen keep coming up with
these videos it's like viral hit after
viral hit and and one video that i
really just want to applaud you on is
you know how open you are about
the industry being so unpredictable
there is an unspoken expectation that as
an actor you're supposed to sit by and
wait for the phone to ring and before
then you don't have an opinion nor
personality
um and
for me it just wasn't working out i had
too much to say i couldn't just sit by
any longer and just wait for the phone
to ring so
and i also think that people have this
perspective on social media where it's
easy to be like oh that doesn't matter
it's social media it's trivial it's dumb
but the truth of the matter is it's just
media
take the word social off it's media i
embrace it and i will continue to going
forward yeah i was just gonna say is
this now a priority as you you know
continue acting and booking jobs and
fulfilling your your actor dreams and
goals yeah for sure just being able to
communicate with people in a direct way
you know without waiting to be given
permission to speak um i think is so
cool is there anything that's gonna be
off limits with your tick tock what a
great question
i don't think so i have nothing to hide
so long as
my content the things that i publish are
continue to be
positive
um
if i if i feel that it's helpful or
inspiring to someone in some way
then um yeah i don't think anything's
off limit we haven't all been together
for christmas in years when's the next
time this is gonna happen mr massey
this one's for you yeah
christmas for keeps what a delightful
holiday film tell me about your
character avery and why did you want to
play her this is the first time that i
read a script that
i really felt like it had a message that
i felt was you know progressive
and
and i really connected with the idea
that this group of friends bonded around
a great leader that they had in their
high school teachers what was it like
being there all together filming a movie
that's seemingly pretty magical it was
absolutely magical okay so we filmed in
vancouver and i don't know if you know
this but vancouver is like hollywood
north pretty much everyone was staying
in like the same hotel we would all like
go out and get dinner together ryan and
i may have hit the casino a couple
nights may have won a ton of money i'm
not saying he's good luck but i'm not
not saying good luck it's no coincidence
that mr massey has brought the two of
you back together again i can't think of
a better way to honor our teacher so
who's in what really stunned me is just
how committed they are to making the
snow
perfect in every every scene there's a
team of like 10 people who are just snow
wranglers i will say for longevity
because the snow obviously melts super
quick and you know it's not perfect
temperature they put down that like
white batting stuff that you like stuff
pillows
they put that over you know on the
ground on the bushes things like that
and then cover it in real snow so it it
reads really well on camera there's so
many heartfelt themes and messages
throughout the movie
what is your
biggest goal or or biggest takeaway that
you hope the audience receives the love
of one's hometown and you know staying
together but also
that sense of leadership and how it can
inspire those around you i think is is
really great there was a teacher that i
had in the third grade mrs farcina shout
out to you wherever you are she wrote a
home a note home to my mom saying this
girl should be an actor my mom was like
what like unprompted it was unrelated to
like you know report card or anything
she just wrote that note and i think
that's when i took the first step to get
into acting classes wow so we credit
that teacher for all the incredible
films and credits to your name to this
day
absolutely yeah she was the best and
that's good
[Music]
leadership you